sono un po di anni che si ripetono che
l'europa install sia bloccato tutto
e guardate che un momento abbastanza
delicato e pericoloso perché l'apnea può
durare solo un periodo di tempo limitato
e quindi è abbastanza importante capire
perché siamo finiti in questo stallo
perché a un certo punto tutto si è
bloccato quel meccanismo semi tomati
dato che era stato messo in piedi e
questo importante capirlo per poter
provare a ripartire
allora io vorrei anzitutto provare a
ragionare in prospettiva un po storica
lo stallo delle europea non ha a che
fare con la cronaca adesso siamo
abituati che ogni giorno ci ripeto che
ci siamo bloccati
è un processo storico molto lungo quale
questo processo storico allora proviamo
a prendere il periodo in cui siete
vissuti vuole sostanzialmente gli
allievi della scuola il sant'anna dal 92
fino al 2016 e lo possiamo spaccare a
metà due primi 12 anni e gli ultimi 12
anni è abbastanza interessante perché
noi abbiamo un punto estremamente
importante nel 92 con il trattato di
maastricht perché usciamo un po
dall'europa solo economica e cominciamo
a fare dei piccoli passi verso
un'integrazione più forte anche su altri
campi a partire dall integrazione
politica
questo percorso continua fino al 2004
perché abbiamo altri trattati che
vengono firmati altri piccoli passi
avanti che non sono dei salti in avanti
enormi che però ci permettono di
continuare ad andare avanti a progredire
il picco di questo ce l'abbiamo nel 2004
quando proviamo addirittura scrivere
tutti insieme una costituzione europea è
però negli anni successivi questa
costituzione viene bocciata quindi è
come se avessimo fatto un po di salita
verso la vetta della montagna e da
allora stessimo ricominciando a scendere
e ricominciando a scendere basta vedere
quello che forse anche tutti voi
ricordate un po più come memoria storia
negli ultimi anni si parla di crisi
dell'euro di crisi della grecia nel 2016
abbiamo sospeso schengen
abbiamo rimesso in discussione uno dei
principi fondamentali su cui è costruita
europa cioè che tutti possiamo liberare
liberamente circolare per non parlare
ovviamente quello che è successo e regno
unito con la black city allora la
domanda è come siamo arrivati in questo
stallo
ora che cosa vuol dire stallo stato
sostanzialmente vuol dire che a un certo
punto non riesci più a raggiungere
dove ti sei dato che fai fatica e ti
fermi da cosa viene questo stallo quali
sono gli obiettivi dell'integrazione
europea che non riusciamo a raggiungere
molto semplicemente pace sicurezza e
prosperità economica e solidarietà ora
fate attenzione adesso che cosa è
successo in maniera abbastanza
interessante nel corso del tempo quando
questi obiettivi sono stati decisi
quindi negli anni cinquanta
semplificando e per i primi decenni
volevano dire delle cose molto concrete
molto specifiche pace e sicurezza
usciamo dalla seconda guerra mondiale
voleva dire scongiurare una nuova era
fra la francia la germania
sostanzialmente la prosperità economica
significa assicurare le quattro libertà
di circolazione quindi beni servizi
capitali e personalità una circolare
liberamente in europa e voleva dire
costruire un mercato unico e la
solidarietà era essenzialmente aveva a
che fare con la politica di coesione con
i fondi strutturali quindi prendere
delle risorse da alcune regioni d'europa
di distribuirle in altre regioni sempre
all'interno della stessa europa
che cosa succede all'inizio degli anni
90 e quindi che cosa è successo da
allora fino ad oggi che noi abbiamo
sempre gli stessi obiettivi di prima ma
per raggiungerlo dobbiamo fare più
quelle cose ora penso che nessuno dubiti
che almeno nel breve periodo
speriamo vediamo che cosa succede tra
fra una settimana
francia e germania cominciano a farsi la
guerra però dobbiamo non per questo fare
delle cose per assicurarci che ci sia
pace sicurezza in europa
semplicemente questa cosa adesso molto
più a che fare con la lotta al
terrorismo con la gestione tra
virgolette dei cosiddetti stati falliti
ciò che gli stati che stanno imponendo
sono storicamente implosi anche alla
frontiera
pensiamo al nord africa dell'europa la
prosperità economica e certamente
completare il mercato unico ma oggi
significa molto più fare dei buoni
accordi internazionali su tante materie
diverse sul commercio sui dati
sull'ambiente e la solidarietà la
solidarietà è ancora fondi strutturali
in buona parte ma soprattutto a che fare
con questioni enormi come le migrazioni
qual è la differenza fra questi due
blocchi per i primi decenni
dell'integrazione europea noi potevamo
raggiungere gli obiettivi che ci siamo
dati semplicemente fra di noi dentro i
nostri confini dentro le nostre
frontiere
devo metterci d'accordo fra europei per
poter avere quegli
che cosa succede all insegna di 90 che
per raggiungere quegli stessi obiettivi
e quindi per fare controllo del
terrorismo per poter fare accordi
internazionali per poter gestire o
provare a gestire l'immigrazione non
bastiamo più dubbi insieme come europei
gestire dialogare e negoziare fuori
dall'europa quindi capite che la cosa
fondamentale che successe che negli
ultimi 25 anni ci siamo inceppati si è
creato questo stallo perché siamo stati
incapaci di adattare le istituzioni che
hanno creato per raggiungere quegli
obiettivi quando bastava gestirsi fra di
noi europei al nuovo mondo e quindi non
siamo riusciti a passare da questo
sguardo interno a questo sguardo esterno
alle nostre frontiere
ora la vera domanda è perché siamo stati
incapaci cioè che cosa è successo allora
le istituzioni che erano state create
all'inizio e che poi hanno preso il nome
di questo metodo comunitario prevedevano
sostanzialmente un meccanismo di
governance perché avevamo paura di fare
il governo di fare il government e
questi siamo concentrati a fare la
governance la governance a prevedeva in
maniera semplificata che c'era la
commissione europea che proponeva e poi
c'erano il parlamento del consiglio che
con decidevano ora il meccanismo era
tutto più complesso ma il principio
generale era che tutti partecipavano
alla presa di decisione quindi è un
processo molto più partecipato molto più
consensuale molto più inclusivo problema
qual era che quando qualcosa non andava
bene quando qualcosa non va bene non sai
con chi piglia tela non c'è
sostanzialmente assunzione di
responsabilità perché tutti hanno
partecipato non è quel meccanismo
classico
ora noi viviamo in un paese in cui
famosa l'espressione piove governo ladro
quindi non voglio dire che dovevamo
necessariamente arrivare fino a lì ma
allo stesso tempo c'era un po più come
dire di complessità a capire la
differenza di responsabilità e chi era
deputato a fare cose a livello europeo
inoltre abbiamo sempre avuto paura della
parola politica a livello europeo
non ho sempre parlato di politiche
quindi le varie come dice pezzi
settoriali che dovevano essere portati
avanti abbiamo avuto sempre un approccio
molto giuridico tutta l'integrazione per
poter fare qualcosa a livello di unione
europea bisognava che ci fosse una base
in un articolo di un trattato e
soprattutto come ad esempio la corte di
giustizia voto ruolo fondamenta
quindi per 30 anni 40 anni
l'integrazione avanzata molto grazie a
una dimensione giuridica e molto poco
politica una dimensione molto tecnica
per non parlare del fatto che abbiamo
dato alle europee l'integrazione europea
molti poteri regolatori
pensate alla politica di concorrenza ma
relativamente un piccolo bilancio e
quando non è un bilancio non puoi fare
vere politiche distributive che cosa è
successo negli ultimi anni negli ultimi
25 anni semplificando abbiamo continuato
ad insistere sul fatto che dovevamo
scampare come la peste qualsiasi forma
di politica come d'europa come spazio
politico
al punto che siamo arrivati quasi al
paradosso di costituzionalizzare tutto
cioè di vincolarci da soli togliendo
dallo spazio decisione politica
qualsiasi decisione il 3 per cento del
rapporto del recinto sul sul pil fissato
a maastricht ha quindi 25 anni fa siamo
veramente sicuri che non si possa
ritoccare che non si possa ridiscutere
che non si possa ripensare oppure è
diventato un dogma totale veramente
anche giusto così ma il fatto che non si
possano imporre discuterne vi dà l'idea
di come abbiamo tentato nel tempo di
imbrigliarci da soli le mani tutti
completamente
per non parlare del fatto da un certo
punto quel triangolo istituzionale tra
commissione parlamento e consiglio è
diventato una piramide e al vertice di
questa piramide c'è il consiglio europeo
quindi le riunioni regolari dei capi di
stato e di governo che ovviamente
decidono tutto è ovviamente le altre
istituzioni sono diventati istituzioni
subordine ma capite che quando a
decidere ea un consesso di capi di stato
e di governo è un consesso in cui ogni
partecipante pensa prima proprio stato
che all'interesse comune e quindi c'è
stata questa profezia di
nazionalizzazione
per non parlare del fatto che noi
abbiamo il parlamento più strepitoso del
mondo in europa il parlamento europeo è
un parlamento che non si può sciogliere
prima del termine è un parlamento che
non esprime la fiducia a un governo
sostanzialmente è un parlamento che non
mette le tasse ora capisco che è
impopolare parlare di tasse però se ci
pensate noi la democrazia in europa a
partire dal regno unito lo abbiamo
costruito sul principio no taxation
without representation
cioè non mi puoi passare se non mi dai
la possibilità di eleggere i
rappresentanti
ora il parlamento ora funziona al
contrario abbiamo i rappresentanti ma
questi rappresentanti non possono alzare
e abbassare le tasse quindi non possono
creare quella dimensione di
quindi le politiche intesa come
maggioranza opposizione come scelte
nette perché non tutte le scelte possono
essere consensuali e quindi che cosa è
successo che quel meccanismo che avevano
inventato per fare l'integrazione
europea un po di pilota semiautomatico
un certo punto negli anni 70 negli anni
80 ha funzionato benissimo per portarci
al 1992 e quindi per sviluppare
quell'integrazione quando dovevamo
decidere solo fra noi europei ma si è
inceppato completamente e non è più
utile per poter fare adesso il passaggio
successivo e sono 25 anni che stiamo un
po arrancando quindi lo stallo attuale
che cosa c da c da che non abbiamo
un'europa attrezzata con strumenti
necessari per raggiungere gli obiettivi
che ci siamo dati guardate che sono
obiettivi importanti non abbiamo
esaurito il potenziale di questo
meccanica istituzionale che ci eravamo
dati
abbiamo invece delle politiche delle
decisioni che dobbiamo prendere molto
poco consensuali e molto divisive
pensate all'immigrazione partendo
dall'assunto che probabilmente nessuno
stato da solo può fare abbastanza
decidere non decidere è molto più
bianconero che non una sfumatura di
tanti grigi mettendo intorno a un tavolo
almeno sui principi di base rispetto
alle decisioni che vogliamo prendere su
quello e ovviamente questo che cosa ha
comportato che rispetto a delle sfide
epocali che avevamo davanti
all'inizio degli anni 90 avevamo
all'avanguardia con europa abbiamo
cominciato ad essere raggiunto da altri
siamo sempre meno all'avanguardia e
stiamo sempre meno capaci
collettivamente come continenti e di
dare risposte ai cittadini a fronte di
queste sfide globali e quindi la
risposta quali è inevitabilmente che i
movimenti reazionari si stanno facendo
largo in tutta europa
mi chiamo relazionali non a caso perché
populisti e una cosa che se qualcuno sta
distratto pensa che c'è dentro la parola
popolo sono quasi bene e poi ormai
qualsiasi cosa non ci piace lo chiamiamo
comunista invece parliamo i movimenti
nazionali la gente che vuole chiudere
vuole mettere i muri che vuole farci
tornare a una specie di epoca dell'oro
che non è mai esistita
ora bastava la depressione che facciamo
nel senso che una volta che tu puoi dire
prendi atto lucidamente che stai un po
andando scivolando pericolosamente che
la storia che sta portando verso un
apnea prolungata che finisce come
sappiamo tutti con il rischio di
affondamento
la domanda che uno si fa ma c'è qualche
speranza in giro secondo me ci sono dei
segnali deboli molto interessanti cioè
inconsciamente o più o meno consciamente
abbiamo costruito comunque anche in
questi 25 anni alcune cose alcune
completate alcune in fieri che stanno un
po lì e che creano un humus fertile su
cui si può intervenire e sono ripetuti
segnali deboli però su cui possiamo da
cui possiamo ripartire
anzitutto la mobilità ora per fare gli
europei non è che lo facciamo con i
trattati non è che lo facciamo lo
facciamo facendo esperienze comuni al di
fuori della nostra ciascuno di noi non
si sente solo necessariamente pisano o
senese un reatino si sente anche
mediamente toscano laziale italiano
perché banalmente lui la sua famiglia o
qualcuno dei suoi amici o qualcuno dei
suoi parenti per larga di ha fatto
l'esperienza in altre città fuori dal
suo comune
ecco la stessa dinamica dobbiamo
riprodurre in europa quindi l'idea un
certo punto di insistere molto sulla
mobilità è fondamentale perché la
mobilità e la connessione in generale ci
porta a fare esperienze comuni che sono
il vero fattore di integrazione quando
per l'integrazione non parliamo di
integrare le istituzioni ma parliamo di
sviluppare un'identità comune che ci
permette di sentirci parte di una
comunità più ampia e qui abbiamo tre
esempi molto semplice molto conosciuti
35 in 30 anni abbiamo tre milioni e
mezzo di studenti erasmus
abbiamo una situazione in cui le
compagnie low cost
cominciano a trasportare più passeggeri
e quindi a facilitare la lo spostamento
degli europei più delle compagnie
tradizionali e abbiamo la fine del
roaming a partire dal 2017 dal giugno
la tecnologia inciso molto su questo
dobbiamo sfruttare 15 anni fa era
impensabile alla fine del roaming perché
tutti dicevano le compagnie della
comunicazione e lo accetteranno mai
poi certo punto qualcuno segmentato
bocciato quindi o lo abbatte o comunque
telefoni gratuitamente lo stesso in giro
per l'europa
secondo aspetto di granello interessante
la sfera pubblica europea ora sfera
pubblica europea
io sono stato parecchio a bruxelles a
bruciare sono tutti convinti che il
resto dell'europa assomiglia a bruxelles
quindi sono tutti di tutto il mondo
tutta europa parlano tutte le lingue e
non si capisce come mai il resto del
mondo non li capisca ecco quando
parliamo di sfera pubblica europea siamo
lane una cosa diversa
stiamo parlando che assistiamo sempre
più spesso a dei giornali
e delle televisioni che lo stesso giorno
danno la stessa notizia in diversi paesi
europei quindi in spagna in francia in
grecia in italia si dibatte lo stesso
giorno dello stesso macro tema
importante semplicemente facciamo e
dibattiti per sì lo so ancora non
sappiamo che quel giorno in cui c'è un
grosso problema di un barcone affondato
nel mediterraneo non se ne parla solo in
italia se ne parla anche in spagna e
quindi si creano delle polarizzazioni
dei dibattiti polarizzati in diversi
paesi
quindi questo è una sfera pubblica
europea incompiuta molto in noce però è
interessante perché a un certo punto si
potrebbe come dire assistere ad
un'evoluzione di questo individuati di
pubblici paneuropei
visto che siamo alla fine a discutere
lungo le stesse linee di divisione sullo
stesso tema lo stesso giorno e poi nei
trattati abbiamo messo qualche segmento
interessante una cittadinanza europea a
partire da maastricht quelli nati dopo
il 1993 sono cittadini europei
io non sono nato cittadino europeo lo
sono diventato però questa cittadinanza
europea presenta un po di quella cosa
che vi dicevo prima di questo approccio
un po troppo giuridico quindi fornisce
garantisce a tutti i cittadini europei
qualche piccolo diritto aggiuntivo
piccolo grande diritto aggiuntivo ma non
ha ancora maturato significativamente
come potrebbe e poi abbiamo questo
strumento molto poco utilizzato che
l'iniziativa europea un milione i
cittadini di sette mesi possono chiedere
alla commissione di proporre di fare
leggi in un determinato ambito su cui
ovviamente lui europea competenza questo
non è stato assolutamente sfruttato ma
in realtà uno strumento potentissimo se
ci ricordassimo che come dire in
democrazia non funzionano solo le
elezioni rappresentativi a un certo
punto i cittadini si possono mobilitare
su delle cose a volte importanti e
potenzialmente di futuro che facciamo
adesso
allora sicuramente va da sé che non
siamo proprio in acque
facilissime perché abbiamo dei seri
problemi di tenuta della democrazia in
alcuni paesi dentro l'unione europea e
per non parlare dei ai confini né
europea e perché assistendo a un ritorno
di povertà e disuguaglianze quindi
abbiamo alcune sfide vocale su cui
dobbiamo operare
allora sono un po di tempo di tempo che
ritorna questo dibattito anche
quest'anno nei 60 anni facciamo l'europa
più velocità proprio più veloce da
significa ormai 28 27 non si capisce
nemmeno troppi prendiamo un nucleo duro
che ci sta e con questo nucleo duro
cerchiamo di avere andare avanti tutti
insieme quali sono i problemi rispetto a
questo questa dinamica primo a non ci
scordiamo che nei trattati
c'è ancora spazio intendo alle regole
del gioco attuali per poter fare delle
piccoli passi avanti ma stiamo ancora
parlando di quello che gli inglesi
definirebbero nice to have delle piccole
cose che aiuterebbero ma che non
cambiano lo schema da gioco generale
secondo prevedere trattati non c'è
storia io quando avevo l'età degli
allievi del sant'anna che frequentano
oggi stavamo alla fine di quel picco di
crescita sostanzialmente è il mantra che
ci ripetevano era se dobbiamo far
avanzare l'europa qual è il prossimo
trattato che facciamo oggi quando ce
l'abbiamo un prossimo trattato il
prossimo trattato servirà per tornare
sarà la prima volta in cui faremo un
trattato per tornare indietro
sarà un trattato che servirà per far
uscire un paese e figuratevi se gli
altri 27 riusciranno mai a mettersi
d'accordo per fare un salto quantico in
avanti quindi non ci sono le condizioni
politiche per fare tramite un approccio
giuridico se volete un come è stato
fatto per 30 anni 40 anni europa un
salto avanti serio ultimo attenzione al
ristorante e al menu l'europa la cart
con la chiamano non confondiamo l'europa
dove lo cita con l'europa la carta
l'europa la carta significa che su ogni
singolo dossier
vediamo quali sono gli stati che sono
d'accordo ad andare avanti il giorno che
ancora vi amo li abbiamo chiuso tutto
perché viene fuori una cacofonia
istituzionale che rispetto alla
governance di cui parlavo prima non lo
capisce più nessuno quindi il sospetto è
che mentre tutti dicono che per salvare
l'europa ci serve qualche ulteriore
riforma istituzionale
aggiungo io purtroppo
probabilmente marginale dobbiamo provare
a pensare da completamente agli antipodi
di questo e quindi mi sono messo a fare
un esercizio molto semplice preso una di
queste parole e ci ho messo lo porta e
ho provato a vedere che cosa veniva
fuori forse dobbiamo tornare a fare quel
che hanno fatto 60 anni fa hanno fatto
60 anni fa forse possiamo riprovare a
fare uno sforzo e a immaginarci qualche
cosa che non sia inerziale incrementare
rispetto al passato però qui abbiamo
usato una parola pomposa rivoluzione ma
in realtà qual è la differenza fra
riforma e le riforme intervengono su
pezzi dello schema e provano a
migliorarlo aggiustarle quei
probabilmente dobbiamo ripensare tutto
lo schema complessivo dobbiamo smettere
di essere istituzionali e dobbiamo
ritornare al primato della politica
molto semplicemente lo capisco che non
va di moda però l'approccio
istituzionale tecnocratico è stato
strepitoso per 40 anni ma adesso non
funziona più quindi inutile accanirsi e
l'ultima ovviamente dobbiamo fare le
cose in maniera netta
dobbiamo ripensare profondamente lo
schema ora per fare questo dobbiamo
provare aggregare e dobbiamo chiederci
però se ci abbiamo abbastanza persone in
giro che hanno voglia tempo testa e
lucidità in questa direzione e quindi io
vi faccio delle domande la prima dove
stanno gli europei perché non è che
questa integrazione europea come dire
sta scritta in qualche testo sacro che
sia la bibbia si al corano né tantomeno
ce l'hanno ordinati medici quindi se ci
rendiamo conto che questa roba funziona
solo perché nel nostro interesse che
quindi siamo diventati tutti troppo
piccoli come stati per poter gestire
alcunché di rilevante per le nostre vite
quotidiane e quindi se non andiamo a
beccare quella parte dei cittadini
europei che già sono consapevoli di
queste programma metterle insieme
rischiamo che gli altri quelli che
vogliono chiudere le frontiere non hanno
bisogno di aggregarsi perché ognuno giu
delle sue di frontiere pro ma anche per
tenerli aperti da un essere tutti
d'accordo tenerle aperte quindi vedrete
che c'è uno svantaggio competitivo
quindi ci dobbiamo attrezzare
organizzare dove sono finiti i nativi
europei nel loro paese con quelli che
secondo me sono nati dopo il 1993 la
cittadinanza allora di che parliamo
prima ora molti dei nostri giovani
molti di voi si sentono già naturalmente
europei sentono a casa ovunque in europa
sono consapevoli di essere cittadini
europei chiuso come identità e spesso
sono anche attivi come cittadini attivi
come attivismo civico me volontariato
nelle proprie comunità
non fate l'errore di pensare che il
mondo in cui siete cresciuti starà lì
per i prossimi 24 25 anni perché se non
ci attiviamo e se non si attiva la parte
più giovane della popolazione europea
in realtà rischiamo di tornare
seriamente indietro e la terza domanda è
l'ultima domanda dov'è finita la
politica la politica intesa come delle
cose belle delle cose nobili
la politica è stata storicamente la
rivendicazione di un diritto si faceva
una battaglia perché uno credeva che
fosse giusto ottenere qualcosa
la politica era la lotta contro
l'ingiustizia la politica da uno
strumento di avanzamento ora vi faccio
notare che tutto questo meccanismo
istituzionale tecnocratico è stato
costruito per 40 anni e che secondo me
ha avuto un valore per quel periodo
storico è nato grazie alla politica
negli anni cinquanta non è nato grazie
alla tecnica oa chissà quale meccanismo
astruso quindi forse dobbiamo riscoprire
la politica e vi faccio notare un'altra
cosa
dal 90 dall 89 e 92 sempre quel periodo
la generazione dei trentenni di oggi di
quarantenni di oggi è cresciuta un po
con l'illusione che ormai la strada
fosse segnata ci fosse quella e bisogna
solo camminare lungo quella strada lì e
quindi ci hanno un po raccontato e noi
ci abbiamo creduto per molti anni che
non servisse la politica se il viso
semplicemente usare buon senso e invece
adesso stiamo scoprendo che il mondo è
molto più polarizzata è molto più diviso
di quello che pensavamo e non siamo
stati apprezzati a gestirlo questo mondo
gestito così è organizzato così e quindi
la riscoperta della politica è
fondamentale per poter ritornare a fare
il tipo di battaglia e c'è sempre anche
perché se non le scopriamo un certo tipo
di politica la politica la faranno
quelli che vogliono uscire la faranno
quelli che quando scendono 250 mila
persone in una piazza in romania fanno
finta di niente e continua andare avanti
con una legge che sana reati di
corruzione e in generale la faranno
quelli che cercano di dividere e di
dividerci
ora c'è un cinese così non parliamo
sempre del
che qualche tempo fa ha detto che il
miglior tempo per piantare un albero era
20 anni fa e che il miglior momento era
adesso signore si chiama confuso ecco a
me sta venendo il dubbio che il miglior
momento per dire fare l'unica cosa che
ci manca in europa dove abbiamo creato
le istituzioni comune abbiamo creato i
cittadini comuni ci manca la politica
comune e quindi come facciamo ad
abbattere le ultime frontiere che poi il
tema il 13 di oggi che sono le frontiere
della politica nazionale e quindi il
miglior momento per partire
probabilmente era nel 92 era quando
dovevamo avremmo dovuto essere molto
lucidi e capire che stava cambiando
tutto che ci saremmo entrare in un lungo
periodo di stallo e quindi forse è
arrivato il momento di far nascere un
movimento politico europeo perché
l'unica maniera che noi possiamo avere
per contrastare tutti coloro che
rischiano invece di approfittare di
questo stallo
guardate non devono fare grandi cose
basta mantenere lo stallo per un altro
po che accogliamo tutti e quindi è
arrivato il tempo di mobilitarsi tutti
ricordandosi una cosa molto bella alla
fine chi è questa qui che siamo tutti
figli delle stelle grazie
[Applauso]